[Musica]
un paio di anni fa curiosando nella
cantina del bisnonno il mio primogenito
diego trovò questo microscopio
quando lo vide diego vuole subito per
ora ad usarlo per cercare di vedere quei
batteri invisibili e misteriosi che il
papa tutti i giorni dice di studiare nel
suo laboratorio
ecco qualche batterio riuscimmo
intravederlo nei bettini preparati ma
diego si legge anche subito conto di
quanto fossi imbranato ad usarli
microscopio e diego ci aveva visto molto
bene non sono in grado di usare il
microscopio perché non uso al
microscopio nel mio laboratorio
a quel punto poi diego ebbe un altra
domande ammesse ma papà quali sono i
batteri che il prozio guardava sotto il
microscopio
non posso saperlo per certo ma può darsi
che si trattasse dello stafilococco
aureo per esempio un batterio che al
giorno d'oggi in alcune sue varianti può
essere distante a qualsiasi antibiotico
oppure lo stretto cocco eccolo qui
oppure ancora le scarica coli un
batterio con il quale diego poi quando
dovete portare a scuola qualcosa di
originale che iniziasse con la lettera e
fece un figurone
ecco questi sono tutti brutti ceffi che
sono stati il principale oggetto di
studio della microbiologia fino adesso
sono i patogeni se entrano in contatto
con il nostro corpo possono creare
infezioni che può andare dall essere
asintomatica al essere mortale
esattamente se ci pensate come il
coronavirus un patogeno virale in questo
caso invece che batterico
ecco la scienza ha imparato a studiare
queste patogeni molto bene e questo ha
portato a grandissimi risultati pensate
per esempio i vaccini
allo stesso tempo ha creato ha fatto di
questi patogeni delle dei patogeni e
molto conosciuti e per questo si
meritano addirittura i peluche dedicati
eccovi il campylobacter per esempio
oppure
questa le nei seria che può causare la
gonorrea
oppure guardate questa è la clamidia
facciamo così adesso vediamo la tira
vediamo chi becco
no scusate mi fanno segno dalla regia
che in tempi di pandemia non sta bene
buttare patogeni sul pubblico
quindi niente
ecco ho spiegato a diego che papà non
studia i batteri in quanto brutti
patogeni cattivi ma studia invece tutti
gli altri microrganismi che popolano il
nostro corpo e non sono patogenici il
mio laboratorio studia il cosiddetto
microbioma umano cioè tutto il corredo
di batteri archeo batteri virus funghi e
parassiti che popola il nostro corpo
pensate che per ognuna cellula umana c'è
almeno una cellula batterica presente
nel nostro corpo e se contassimo anche i
virus i virus quelli buoni non i
patogeni
beh non ci sarebbe storia il nostro
corpo è popolato più da cellule non
nostre che da nostre stesse cellule
questa vastità microbica popola il
nostro intestino il nostro stomaco
cavità orale bocca denti pelle ha
parlato rose in italy e molti altri
organi interni del nostro corpo in cui
microbioma gioca un ruolo fondamentale
pensate per esempio alla regolazione del
nostro metabolismo
ci sono alcune vitamine importanti per
il nostro corpo che non possiamo
assumere con il cibo che il nostro corpo
non è in grado di produrre e solo alcuni
membri del microbioma se ne possono
fornire
oppure c'è la regolazione del sistema
immunitario così poi quando arrivano i
brutti ceffi patogeni sappiamo
difenderci oppure ancora pensate il
microbioma è in grado di dialogare
direttamente con il nostro sistema
nervoso centrale quindi batteri
dialogano con il nostro cervello
ecco potrei continuare ore a parlarvi di
quali sono le funzioni del microbioma e
molti queste comunque restano
completamente sconosciute ma la cosa
importante è che dobbiamo considerare il
microbioma come un organo tutti gli
effetti diffuso all'interno del nostro
corpo
ma come aveva intuito diego non usiamo
il microscopio per studiare il
microbioma semplicemente perché è quasi
impossibile riuscire a coltivare tutti i
batteri del microbioma e poi osservarli
al microscopio
quello che invece facciamo è usare la
cosiddetta metagenomica la metà genomica
usa due strumenti principali il
sequenziatore e il computer l'idea
principale è di accedere direttamente al
materiale genetico di del microbioma per
cercare di capire cosa sia quindi quello
che facciamo è prendere un campione un
campione di microbioma questo vuol dire
un grammo di feci una goccia di saliva
un tampone cutaneo e quello che facciamo
è estrarre il materiale genetico da
questo campione il dna il dna poi lo
diamo in pasto al sequenziatore che lo
legge questi sequenziatori sono nuove
macchine biotecnologiche in grado di
leggere piccoli pezzettini di dna di
codice genetico ma sono in grado di
farlo milioni e milioni di volte questo
crea un flusso di informazione genetica
e genomica enorme che deve essere
interpretata con il computer
precisamente con algoritmi informatici
statistici di intelligenza artificiale
come abbiamo sentito prima per cercare
di dare un senso al microbioma e queste
sono tutte discipline molto quantitative
che non sono state propriamente il
centro della biologia classica per così
dire fino ad adesso
ma il passaggio dell'analisi del
computer è veramente fondamentale per
fare un esempio è un po come cercare di
risolvere un enorme puzzle genomico per
ognuno degli organismi perché dobbiamo
partire fondamentalmente da tutti i
pezzettini di dna incastrarli allinearli
uno con l'altro per cercare di
ricostruire il puzzle genomico
dell'organismo che stiamo guardando
però nella meta genomica e sappiamo che
il microbioma è composto da migliaia un
migliaio di organismi quindi quello che
dobbiamo fare è cercare di risolvere
contemporaneamente migliaia e migliaia d
pad allo stesso tempo con la difficoltà
aggiuntiva che qualcuno ci ha preso
tutti i pezzettini di tutti i puzzle
elia mescolati in un unico calderone
ecco la parte informatica di questo
processo è talmente importante che vi
posso svelare che io di formazione sono
un informatico non un microbiologo e
proprio perché sono informatico posso in
realtà essere oggi qui a parlarvi di
microbioma di salute e di collegamento
tra microbioma e salute
la meta genomica ha rivoluzionato il
modo in cui interpretiamo quello che non
è umano all'interno di noi e la metà
genomica usata anche nel mio blog a
torio e questo ha portato alcune
scoperte che vi vorrei brevemente
illustrare
una delle linee di ricerca principali
che ci ha occupato negli ultimi cinque
anni è stata quella di studiare il
microbioma in quasi 10 mila individui
diversi provenienti da trenta
popolazioni mondiali
queste popolazioni siccome sappiamo che
il sì che lo stile di vita un'influenza
sui nostri microbioma abbiamo anche
campionato popolazioni cosiddette non
occidentalizzate quindi che non hanno
accesso alla nostra dieta ad alto
contenuto di grassi e di zuccheri
raffinati e che anche non hanno accesso
a dispositivi medici antibiotici
quello che abbiamo fatto e applicare la
metà genomica tutti i diecimila questi
individui e abbiamo ricostruito negli
anni centinaia di migliaia di puzzle
genomici questi puzzle poi abbiamo
cercato di organizzarli quindi puzzle
simili in individui diversi li abbiamo
messi insieme abbiamo raggruppati nella
stessa specie e quello che c'è il
risultato è questo albero genealogico di
tutti i microrganismi che popolano il
nostro corpo tecnicamente si chiama un
albero filogenetico e potete
interpretarlo come ogni puntino ogni
foglia di questo albero è una specie un
tipo di batterio presente nel nostro
corpo
ma questo punto la cosa straordinaria
che abbiamo visto è che più di tre
quarti di queste specie di questi
puntini rappresenta specie che nessuno
aveva mai mai visto quindi organismi che
nessuno aveva mai visto al microscopio
che nessuno aveva mai chiamato per nome
che nessuno aveva osservato in nessun
modo
pensate a questo punto lo stupore delle
ragazze nei ragazzi il mio laboratorio
quando si sono trovati di fronte una
cosa così mai vista e su vasta scala se
ci pensate un po come scoprire nuove
stelle o addirittura intere nuove
galassie quella grande differenza almeno
per me che non si tratta di qualcosa ad
anni luce di distanza da noi ma si
tratti di qualcosa
presente dentro di noi che fa parte di
noi e che ha un influenza sulla nostra
stessa salute
uno di questi organismi
uno di questi puntini rappresenta un
batterio di cui abbiamo visto il puzzle
genomico in migliaia di individui
diversi questo è risultato essere il
settimo batterio più abbondante nel
nostro corpo era un batterio
completamente sconosciuto
e siccome era anche così abbondante
abbiamo avuto l'onore in realtà di
poterlo battezzare l'abbiamo chiamato
cibi ogni bacter dal nome del nostro
dipartimento
e adesso stiamo cercando di capire cosa
diavolo faccia questo cibi un ibac
dentro di noi dentro tutti noi e anche
se non separavamo che si chiamasse in
questo modo
ecco stiamo adesso analizzando tutti gli
altri puntini che vedete qui per cercare
di interpretarli e dare un nome sensato
ad ognuno di queste migliaia di batteri
sarà solo il primo dei problemi che
avremo ma allo stesso tempo anche senza
sapere senza avere un nome possiamo
guardare al genoma di questi organismi e
cercare di capire cosa stiano facendo vi
faccio un piccolo esempio abbiamo
trovato che in alcuni microrganismi
sconosciuti molto abbondanti in
popolazioni non occidentalizzate c'è la
presenza di un gene che codifica per un
enzima in grado di degradare fibre
vegetali complesse e non processate
questi geni questi enzimi sono molto
meno abbondanti nel nostro corpo
questo probabilmente non vi sorprende
sapendo la differenza di dieta che vi
dicevo prima dalla popolazione
occidentalizzate e non occidentalizzate
ma ci ha fatto formulare un'ipotesi ben
precisa non è che lo stile di vita post
rivoluzione industriale abbia indotto
una modificazione nostra microbioma che
ha portato alla perdita di alcuni
batteri importanti
forse non ci importa anche se ci
dovrebbe importare che perdiamo alcuni
geni che in grado di radar e fibre
versali complesse ma quegli stessi
batteri portano migliaia di altri geni
migliaia di altre funzioni importanti
per il nostro corpo che perdiamo allo
stesso tempo ma siccome questa è
un'ipotesi abbiamo dovuto verificarla e
per rispondere questa domanda abbiamo
preso la macchina del tempo siamo andati
a chiederlo a questo nostro antenato lo
conoscerete hai vissuto 5300 anni fa
l'uomo del ghiaccio ritrovato sul
similaun in alto adige e che e ci ha
svelato questo mistero forse avete già
capito dove voglio arrivare ma con
l'aiuto dei gli scienziati dell'istituto
che conserva la mummia siamo andati ad
applicare la meta genomica al contenuto
intestinale dell'uomo del viaggio
per una volta quello che questa analisi
ha detto è esattamente quello che ci
aspettavamo cioè abbiamo trovato quei
batteri sconosciuti presenti molto
abbondantemente popolazioni non
occidentalizzate che noi abbiamo perso
attendiamo perdere ecco che l'uomo del
ghiaccio dal passato viene a dirci
attenzione che lo stile di vita non
appropriato una salute non sana può
portare a gravi
problemi nei nostri nel nostro
microbioma che può causare problemi di
salute
allo stesso tempo però se ci pensate il
fatto che la nostra dieta modifichi il
nostro microbioma può essere anche una
buona notizia perché se impariamo a
modificare il nostro microbioma nel modo
voluto grazie alla dieta vuole anche
dire che possiamo avere un alleato il
microbioma per ripristinare il nostro
stato di salute o per diminuire il
rischio di alcune malattie e soprattutto
quelle immunologiche immunomediate e
metaboliche per non parlare anche dei
tumori come stiamo vedendo nelle ultime
ricerche
ecco un'altra domanda che ci siamo
chiesti secondo me molto rilevante è
stata quella di capire il microbioma
come se origini dentro di noi
noi sappiamo che il feto il bambino
prima della nascita e in condizioni di
sterilità in gravidanze non
problematiche e allora importante capire
quando entriamo a contatto con il
microbioma quand'è che il micro biomasse
colonizza per rispondere questa domanda
siamo andati a fare uno studio
all'ospedale santa chiara di trento e
abbiamo arruolato future madri e
l'abbiamo campionate per il microbioma
in vari punti del corpo
abbiamo anche arruolato i neonati
corrispondenti e quello che abbiamo
trovato è che componenti uniche del
microbioma di ogni madre le abbiamo
ritrovate solamente nel neonato
corrispondente quindi abbiamo avuto
l'evidenza chiara che c'è trasmissione
di batteri dalla madre al bambino già
durante il parto con batteri del canale
vaginale e dell'intestino della madre
che durante il parto vengono trasmette
trasmessi al neonato e dopo la nascita
ha un ruolo anche il microbioma della
madre cutaneo e orale e poi anche quello
del latte il latte materno non contiene
solo i nutrienti
importantissimi per il neonato ma
contiene anche i batteri in grado di
digerire e processare questi nutrienti
importanti
ecco
il problema con sorgere quando una madre
deve
deve avere un parto cesareo deve
ricorrere al parto cesareo una parte di
una pratica medie medica importantissima
ovviamente oppure non può allattare al
seno in questi casi si nota che il
microbioma non viene colonizzato nel
neonato nella maniera ideale
ma anche in questo caso la salute dal
punto di vista medico le nuove frontiere
della medicina hanno imparato a venirci
il nostro aiuto ci sono studi clinici
che hanno mostrato come l'inoculo di una
piccolissima quantità di microbioma
materno il neonato nato per parto
cesareo ripristini completamente la
naturale fisiologia della colonizzazione
dello sviluppo del microbioma nel
neonato
tecnicamente questo si chiama trapianto
fecale che probabilmente non è la cosa
prudente più pulita o più o che vorremmo
tutti fare però è una pratica medica
importantissima che sta salvando vite
anche nell'adulto e soprattutto adulti
che hanno problemi di infezioni
resistenti a qualsiasi antibiotico il
microbioma riesce a ristabilire il
giusto la giusta qualità microbica in
grado di combattere il patogeno
ecco il trapianto fecale c ribadisce
un'altra cosa secondo me che forse la
più importante di tutti il nostro
microbioma è modulabile il nostro genoma
il genoma umano rimane quello durante
tutta la nostra vita
il microbioma possiamo modificarlo e
siccome microbioma una grandissima
influenza sulla nostra salute abbiamo
una modalità nuova a cui la medicina si
sta aprendo per poter agire sulla nostra
salute e soprattutto il rischio di
future malattia
ecco quando sono arrivato al laboratorio
al dipartimento cibjo dell'università di
trento 10 anni fa ormai si sapeva poco
del microbioma umano con gli sviluppi
della metà genomica adesso c'è una
rivoluzione completa in atto e sono
veramente orgoglioso che anche membri
del mio laboratorio con le ricerche
abbiamo fatto abbiano potuto contribuire
a questa rivoluzione
ricordiamoci siamo un ecosistema
complesso e dobbiamo continuare a
studiare questa complessità non solo dal
punto di vista delle nostre stesse
cellule un punto di vista se volete
prettamente antropocentrico ma dobbiamo
farlo anche dal punto di vista di tutte
le altre cellule non nostre microbiche
che compongono il nostro corpo
e a questo punto non posso che lasciarvi
augurandomi che magari tra tre o quattro
anni su questo palco si possa presentare
qualche ragazza qualche ragazzo del mio
laboratorio che invece di tirarvi questi
brutti patogeni che ho cercato di
tirarvi oggi ripresentino magari il
peluche del cb uni bacter che sarà
diventato famoso perché è importante per
la nostra salute o magari di qualche
altro eroe positivo del nostro
microbioma
grazie
[Applauso]